for this week's video I'm in beautiful
Cancun Mexico
yeah it's work-related
last year with the Copenhagen flop so
this year the UN opted for a refreshing
change of pace by bringing their climate
summit to the tropical Wonderland of is
Cancun Mexico and what goes on here well
there's a lot of talking and a lot of
meeting and talking and meeting and
sometimes they take meetings just to
talk so I'm out front of the Cancun mess
where many of the events and seminars
and panels are being held and to go in
there and it looks almost exactly like a
student signs fair yet people with their
booths and their bristol boards and
their petitions and it's a great time
for all self-important people every
country has a race to develop but we
also have to make sure the money and
support is there to ensure that clean
technologies and green developments
possible and essential for us I know
it's for for helping the degreaser
you see all ships that is co2 and in the
world so I think basically we should
support all the things like fast
otherwise we're gonna have problems with
the warming the goats global warming and
I just hope that this works science
they're telling us we need to be
reducing our transmission
seiyya large mate very quick please oh
yes he reducing and ultimately staffing
emissions is the name of the game even
President Obama jumped aboard that
bandwagon by touting his support for an
aggressive initiative to reduce the
United States emissions by 68 percent
come 2050 it should be noted that that
would actually have our mission levels
back to where they were around 1905 a
time when nearly no Americans had cars
dishwashers washing machines or
electricity and the average life
expectancy was a right 47 years old if
you made a past childhood without being
kicked by a horse you were pretty much
in the clear now see while many
Americans may see this as regressive new
environmentalists see that as progress
for Mother Earth but at least they do
understand the sacrifices necessary to
reduce the impact of climate change yes
adjustments and sacrifices like no
longer conjugating in cool
air-conditioned halls with refrigerators
full of cold beer and popsicles okay so
clearly if these folks
deamon acceptable to enjoy their own
frozen treats they can't be extremists
right they would want us all to be
reasonable I'm sure you've got some
folks like the respected head of the
Tyndall center for climate change
professor Kevin Anderson actually
calling for the halting of economic
growth in wealthy countries and
government rationing like those in the
30s and 40s quote the second world war
and the concept of rationing is
something that we need to seriously
consider if we are to address the scale
of the problem we face talk about messed
up but I'm sure the folks here in Cancun
are far more reasonable and would call a
guy out like that on his crazy talk
after all they do eat popsicles would
you support initiative like like
rationing but for fighters
I'm not too sure really has no issue I
think it's
I don't know huh even implement what I
think it's a very complex team as out of
the climate change just say no the
answer is no rationing really these
people are eating popsicles which also
begs the question how do you get here
but all of us flu it's very long
distance from can go to Mexico City so
you have to take a plane Oh see that's
why I guess we had to fly to two hours
I know apparently these folks have never
heard of Skype so millions of dollars
and God knows how many tons of carbon
emissions later these folks congregate
here in Cancun to talk about the
buzzword of the day the Kyoto Protocol
it's a protocol ah yes the Kyoto
Protocol gives or broken global the
world government climate bill that has
everybody here all atwitter the thing is
with the Kyoto Protocol be geared to a
protocol despite it being radically
expensive even if all nations signed it
and obeyed it its own supporters have
admitted that it wouldn't do much to
reduce the temperatures come target time
and that's assuming that all nations
obey it see the European Union's target
goal was to reduce its emissions by 8
percent below 1990 levels come 2012
between the year 2000 and 2004 they saw
their emissions rise by a level of 9
percent on average you compare that to
the average rise of the American levels
by 1.7 percent despite us not being on
Forbes the protocol to appropriable
because it's designed to hurt us
economically more than them but when all
is said and done renewable energy come
on that's good for everybody
right
the fact is there is a reason that we
haven't switched to these supposed to
renewable energy resources they're
unreliable and often very expensive
Barack Obama himself so that under his
cap-and-trade plan electricity rates
would necessarily skyrocket companies
would have to retrofit their operations
and those costs would be passed on to
the consumer
now while higher gas prices and energy
cost might seem like a mere nuisance to
the UN delegates enjoying the resorts
and spas of Cancun for other people the
results can be deadly I had the
privilege of heading out to La Libertad
a small village in rural Mexico where
people live without water or electricity
this lady welcomed us into her home and
showed us how she was forced to cook for
her family
see this ironing board acts as a stove
with anything she can find the light
underneath it acting as fuel as a matter
of fact over 1.4 billion people still
lack electricity in the world today and
over 3 billion still require solid fuel
for cooking the reason she couldn't use
her gas stove is because cooking one pot
of beans would use up her gas allotment
for the week and that's all she can
afford so she's forced to ration it
wisely
she also sadly doesn't have enough money
to send her youngest daughter to public
school so she teaches her at home
suddenly those necessarily skyrocketing
energy rates that barack obama brags
about take on a whole new meaning they
have them head and shoulders here will
be dandruff free at least now the
organization that took me here see fact
helps provide batteries and solar panels
to homes and schools neighborhood I was
lucky enough to visit one of them they
invited us with open arms
I taught them such fine American customs
as the high five Charleston and the
Carlton
tell us your bill these climate colleges
have green energy and renewable energy
how do these these bills the initiatives
affect third world countries like those
people truly trying to come out of
poverty well I think one of the things
that people should recognize by the ways
that people in the developing world
don't think about these issues it's he
it's and you know that's all they're
interested in is eating so for the most
part what you're looking at in the in
countries like this villages like this
are people just trying to make a make a
living energy prices are terribly
expensive other people here work for
very little money each day if policies
coming out of the camp and conference go
forward and Energy's made more extensive
the people here will struggle in the
last you know they talk about going to
renewable energy things like wind and
solar these things do drive up cost they
do cost jobs expensive not practical and
they are made they make life very
difficult and more things more expensive
but here in the developing world it can
be catastrophic well that is true take
into account that coal power costs about
seven point eight cents per kilowatt
hour and compare that to the renewable
wind energies coming in over at 12 cents
and it's easy to see why states with
renewable energy mandates often end up
paying an average of 40 percent more for
their electricity well that may sound
like a panic to Americans for the
children of a Libertad it could be the
difference between a 14 school clothes
or even food
hey maybe the Mexican government could
have given those children the 60 plus
million that they actually spent on this
conference no that's just crazy talk and
wouldn't make headlines but of course
that in a nutshell is how going green
affects third-world countries they won't
have the chance to pull themselves out
of poverty as we have here in the new
world and with fewer and fewer countries
being exempt from emission standards
it's going to become increasingly
difficult but see the environmentalism
movement today is pro mother earth and
human life is often seen as nothing more
than a byproduct or a nuisance so it's
important remember well going green may
make us in North America feel warm and
fuzzy forcing it upon those who can't
afford that privilege
well to them it could be fatal but I
guess if these folks would rather die
then they better do it and decrease the
surplus population definitely be the
green thing to do
this is orange papaya I wanted mango
orange